merci chers collègues la parole est à
pierre charon du groupe ump pour 12
minutes
vous avez la parole cher collègue madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre mais
ce président de la commission des lois
sera porteur cher françois zocchetto mes
chers collègues la l'examen de la
présente proposition de loi tendant à
reconnaître le vote blanc nous impose
une réflexion conduite avec méthode
en premier lieu il est nécessaire que
nous nous accordions sur la définition
du vote blanc ainsi nous devons
identifier la signification de cet acte
afin de lui donner une substance
juridique
une fois ces deux définitions arrêté il
nous sera alors possible de passer à la
seconde étape de notre réflexion à
savoir quelle place devant nous et
pouvons nous lui accorder dans le code
électoral et cela en gardant en tête
deux impératifs constitutionnels
la protection est l'expression
pluraliste des opinions et l'élection à
la majorité des suffrages exprimés des
élus de la république
revenons donc à la définition du vote
blanc a son origine dans son sens
profond je ne vous ferai pas grâce du
rappel historique
madame l'ip est puisque vous même vous y
avez cédé le vote blanc est un concept
ancien qui dans le cadre de la
république française remonte à l'an 6
comme le rappeler à monsieur hôpitaux
c'est à dire à 1998 où une noire
reconnaissait l'existence de ce dernier
en même temps que le vote par bulletin
est systématisé après avoir disparu
il ferait établi son premier remplir
afin de disparaître à nouveau
c'est donc au gré des besoins de
l'histoire que le législateur se
confrontent régulièrement à cette
question quel est le sens de cette
interrogation aujourd'hui que signifie
le désir de comptabiliser le vote blanc
et de l'intégrer aux suffrages exprimés
le besoin de reconnaissance du vote
blanc est donc de dire et des pardons et
donc de différenciation par rapport aux
votes nuls augmente proportionnellement
au sentiment d'insatisfaction vis-à-vis
de la classe politique
or ce sentiment d'insatisfaction et de
deux natures
il peut traduire l'absence de pleurer de
pluralité de l'offre qui pousse le
lecteur qui s'est déplacé à ne pas faire
de choix parmi l'offre et soit le
sentiment de défiance vis-à-vis des
appareils politiques en général
l'auteur du vote blanc peut donc
potentiellement envoyé deux messages
distincts je ne suis pas satisfait par
l'offre proposée je ne crois pas à la
sincérité des offres or peut-on
légitimement considérer que ces postures
sont infondées ce sentiment est il
uniquement le fruit d'une société qui
doute de tout y compris d'elle-même non
je crois que le moins que l'on puisse
faire c'est justement de ne pas enlever
aux citoyens le droit de nous envoyer un
message
cette démarche qui tend donc à une plus
grande reconnaissance du vote blanc est
d'autant plus fondé qu'elle va garantir
la libre expression de la pluralité des
opinions
si le système politique ne permet pas la
représentation de sensibilité singulière
au motif que le code électoral et le
système politique ne sont pas de nature
à favoriser l'émergence de partis
courant ou individus ont décalage avec
le monde politique et médiatique
alors il devient impératif de considérer
le vote blanc comme l'expression d'un
sentiment et même d'un message politique
or cette reconnaissance de l'existence
d'un vol blanc qui serait l'expression
d'un message politique n'existe pas à
l'heure actuelle nous sommes donc tous
d'accord dans cette assemblée pour
reconnaître le caractère politique du
vote blanc caractère qui doit être
reconnu à présent il nous faut savoir
comment cette absence de reconnaissance
se matérialisent car l'état actuel du
droit en matière de vote blanc nous
indiquera comment lui donner une
substance juridique
il ya donc deux réseaux plutôt deux
barrières
la non-reconnaissance du moulin blanc la
première est qu'il n'y a pas aujourd'hui
de distinction entre le vote nul et le
vote blanc la seconde est que le vote
blanc n'est pas intégré dans le suffrage
exprimé
or cette intégration qui est de fait
impossible si on considère que le vote
blanc équivaut à vos tenues
ainsi comme nous venons de le voir la
reconnaissance du vote blanc comprend
deux degrés distincts la différenciation
des votes blancs et les votes nuls qui
assimile de fait le vote blanc à une
erreur ou une volonté de ne pas se
soumettre aux règles régissant le
scrutin et l'intégration du vol blanc
dans les suffrages exprimés
nous verrons plus tard quel degré de
reconnaissance doit être instituée en
attendant il nous faut opérer une
distinction entre votes blancs et nuls
mais de fait il apparaît certain qu'à
l'issue de l'examen de cette proposition
de loi
nous devrons comme le prévoit le texte
qui nous est soumis opérer une
distinction entre votes blancs et vote
nul ainsi le vote nul n'a que deux
origines la maladresse de l'électeur
conduisant par exemple ces derniers à
introduire deux bulletins dans l'
enveloppe ou la volonté de ne pas se
soumettre aux règles régissant le
scrutin en inscrivant par exemple des
signes de reconnaissance des injures ou
un suffrage qui n'est pas clairement
exprimé comme pour les scrutins de liste
je ne parlerai pas des fraudes
quelle que soit l'origine de ce vote nul
il est sain d'opérer une différence
entre bulletins blancs et nuls à la
condition que le vote blanc par
convention soit considéré comme
l'expression d'une opinion ce qui
traditionnellement est admis en france
partant de ce postulat il nous faut donc
des éléments pour différencier le
suffrages non exprimés qui contient un
message politique du suffrage de
n'exprimer qui relève de l'erreur ou de
la volonté de ne pas se soumettre aux
règles du scrutin
pour réaliser cela et même si la volonté
de ne pas respecter les règles du
scrutin peut dans une certaine mesure
epr à simuler un message politique
par commodité il faut admettre une
définition très large du vote nul
et par voie de conséquence une
définition restrictive du vote blanc ou
du moins
définition qu'ils ne puissent faire
l'objet d'aucune ambiguïté nous avons vu
que le vote blanc qui doit faire l'objet
d'une reconnaissance accrue dans la
mesure où il peut s'agir de l'expression
d'une opinion peut et doit se définir de
manière très précise pour cette raison
il faut soutenir toute initiative qui
viserait à clarifier et encadrer ce type
de suffrages reste la question de
l'intégration des votes blancs dans la
comptabilité des suffrages exprimés
ce texte ne prévoit pas aujourd'hui et
il faudrait sans doute prendre le temps
de se confronter à toutes les questions
que cela pose en particulier de
modification de la constitution
l'article 7 précise en effet que le
président de la république est élu à la
majorité absolue des suffrages exprimés
le passage de la majorité absolue à la
majorité relative a de nombreuses
conséquences sur lesquels il n'est pas
question de s'attarder aujourd'hui mais
il me semble qu'il s'agirait là d'un
horizon intéressant nos institutions
tiennent leur force de leur légitimité
voilà fiction de la majorité absolue
commence à s'effriter et afin de la
préserver il faut sans doute l'encré
plus clairement dans le réel
accepter la loi de la majorité c'est la
base de notre démocratie
en revanche ne pas comptabiliser ceux
qui disent non c'est prendre le risque
de voir se développer une défiance
sourde et dangereuse pour nos
institutions
mes chers collègues nous devrions lire
le vote blanc comme un thermomètre de la
démocratie et non comme une vague
fantaisie des lecteurs la dernière
élection présidentielle nous offre un
exemple concret et sans doute françois
hollande aurait été invité à plus
d'humilité devant la victoire si le
calcul avait intégré le vote blanc
ramenant son score sans doute et bien
sûr autour de 48%
cette vérité des chiffres ne retirerait
en rien la légitimité de son élection
mais mesurer la nature de la majorité
permettrait une forme de finesse dans
l'exercice du pouvoir
pour conclure comme nous l'avons vu la
question de la reconnaissance et de la
comptabilisation du vol blanc pose de
très nombreuses questions techniques
ce texte est sans doute une première
étape pour avancer vers la
reconnaissance de tout ce qui est
jusqu'à présent sont un peu trop
rapidement glissé sous le tapis mais le
message important de cette proposition
est en réalité le suivant il ya une
différence entre les lecteurs j'y reste
au lit le dimanche matin est celui qui
va faire la queue devant l'isoloir pour
dire non nous ne pouvons paris d'un
trait de plume ces français qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans l'offre politique
nous ne pouvons pas faire l'impasse sur
le message de détresse que ses électeurs
nous envoie en refusant de donner sa
voix au candidat en lice nous ne pouvons
tout simplement pas mais privé le choix
de ces français c'est pourquoi bien
qu'il ne s'agisse là que d'un premier
pas et qui méritera sûrement des
réflexions ultérieure le groupe ump
votera ce texte je vous remercie
merci monsieur charon